E
BIDEN FAMILY WAS DOING.
HERE IT IS.
>> TONY BOBULINSKI, THANK YOU
FOR COMING.
IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS SINCE WE SAT
ACROSS FROM EACH OTHER.
I DIDN'T EXPECT TO HAVE A SECOND
INTERVIEW WITH YOU.
I AM GRATEFUL THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO.
THANK YOU.
WHEN WE SPOKE BEFORE, YOU
DESCRIBED WHAT YOU BELIEVE WERE
HUNTER BIDEN AND THE BIDEN
FAMILY'S EFFECTIVELY OFFENSES
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES.
THE WAYS THAT THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES HAD UNDERMINED U.S.
NATIONAL SECURITY.
BUT THERE WAS ALSO AN OFFENSE
AGAINST YOU.
IT SEEMED LIKE FRAUD.
NOW TWO YEARS LATER I THINK WE
HAVE A PRETTY HARD EXAMPLE OF
WHAT THAT LOOKED LIKE.
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND EXPLAINING
TO US, THIS IS GOING BACK TO THE
SPRING AND SUMMER OF 2017.
WHAT WAS THAT?
>> SINO HAWK HOLDINGS WAS A
DELAWARE LLC THAT WAS
EFFECTIVELY A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE BIDEN FAMILY,
MYSELF, ROB WALKER AND JAMES
KILLIER AND A CHINESE LARGE
COMPANY CALLED CFC, WHICH TURNED
OUT TO BE EFFECTIVELY A
CAPITALISTIC ARM OF THE
PRESIDENT ONE ROAD.
THIS ENTITY THAT CHAIRMAN OF CFC
AND AN ENTITY CALLED HUDSON
OWNED 50% OF SINO HAWK HOLDINGS
AND AN ENTITY THAT REPRESENTED
THE BIDEN FAMILY, MYSELF, JAMES
GILLIARD CALLED UNITE OH
HOLDINGS ON THE OTHER 50% OF
THAT ENTITY.
>> AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS DEAL
AT THE CHINESE WERE SUPPOSED TO
SEND SINO HAWK MONEY.
HOW MUCH?
>> I AM GLAD YOU ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
A LOT OF DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
ABOUT THE $10 MILLION THE
CHINESE WERE SUPPOSED TO FUND
INTO SINO HAWK HOLDINGS.
$5 MILLION OF THAT WAS
REPRESENTING THEIR 50% AND THE
$50 MILLION THEY WOULD CALL IT
ALONE TO THE BIDEN FAMILY BUT
EFFECTIVELY IT WAS A LONE TO
REPRESENT THE ORIGINAL OPERATING
CAPITOL.
THAT WAS JUST OPERATING CAPITOL.
THE SINO HAWK HOLDINGS WAS SET
UP TO DEFECTIVELY DEPLOY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT CFC WAS
CLAIMING AND RIGHTFULLY
BELIEVABLE BECAUSE THEY WERE
DOING IT AROUND THE WORLD TO
INVEST VIA SINOHAWK IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS,
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES, INVESTMENT
BANKS, FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS,
BOTH HERE, THE U.S. AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
>> THIS IS THE LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANY AGREEMENT OF SINOHAWK
HOLDINGS.
IT SAYS HERE MAY 2017.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> THAT IS ACTUALLY A VERY
INTENSE LEGAL DOCUMENT THAT IS
DRAFTED AND DETAILS HOW SINOHAWK
HOLDINGS WILL OPERATE, WHO ARE
THE PARTNERS INVOLVED IN THE
ENTITY.
IT BASICALLY DICTATES HOW THE
BUSINESS AND WHO SITS ON THE
BOARD OF IT, WHO WILL RUN IT DAY
TODAY.
I WAS THE CEO OF SINOHAWK
HOLDINGS AND WAS VESTED WITH
CERTAIN RIGHTS AND AUTHORITIES
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
AND HOW YOU WOULD DISTRIBUTE
PROFITS TO THE PARTNERS AND
STUFF.
A VERY DETAILED DOCUMENT AND
FULLY EXECUTED.
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE WIN I
CAME OUT IN OCTOBER 2020, A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARGUED THAT DEAL NEVER
HAPPENS.
THAT DEAL 100% HAPPEN.
THE SINOHAWK DOCUMENT YOU ARE
HOLDING WAS FULLY EXECUTED BOTH
BY JIM BIDEN, HUNTER BIDEN,
MYSELF, JAMES GILLIARD, ROB
WALKER.
ON THE CHINESE SIDE HUDSON
EXECUTED THE DOCUMENTS.
IT WAS A FULLY OPERATING
BUSINESS.
>> HERE'S A VERY STRANGE
DOCUMENT.
I HOPE YOU CAN EXPLAIN IT.
THIS IS A LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANY AGREEMENT OF THE YZ
HOLDINGS LLC.
THIS IS FROM AUGUST 2ND, 2017,
THREE MONTHS LATER.
THE REASON THIS IS STRANGE IS
THIS DOCUMENT IS IDENTICAL DOWN
TO THE SERIAL NUMBERS ON THE
BOTTOM OF THE PAGE TO THIS
DOCUMENT, THE SINOHAWK HOLDINGS
AGREEMENT, EXCEPT IT HAS A
DIFFERENT COMPANY NAME.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> INTERESTING.
THAT DOCUMENT IS EXACTLY THE
SAME DOCUMENT THAT SINOHAWK
HOLDINGS LLC AND IT APPEARS THAT
HUNTER BIDEN, JIM BIDEN AND THE
BIDEN FAMILY LITERALLY COPIED
THE SAME DOCUMENT DOWN TO TYPOS
AND THE SERIAL NUMBER AND THEY
REMOVED ONEIDA HOLDINGS, WHICH
WAS THE DELAWARE LLC THAT
REPRESENTED JIM BIDEN, HUNTER
BIDEN, MYSELF, ROB WALKER AND
JAMES GILLIARD.
HUNTER AND HIS LAWYER REPLACED
IT WITH HUNTER BIDEN'S LAW FIRM
OR BUSINESS THAT HE OPERATED.
HE EFFECTIVELY SWAPPED OUT AN
ENTITY THAT HE OWNED 20% OF TO A
BUSINESS THAT HE OWNED 100% OF,
WHICH IS FRAUD.
>> WHY WOULD HE DO THAT?
>> A LOT OF DETAIL THAT WE DON'T
HAVE.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
>> AT A HIGH LEVEL IN JULY 2017
THE CHINESE CFC HAD NOT FUNDED
THE $10 MILLION.
I WAS EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED.
THE BIDENS CLAIMED OR PRESENTED
TO BE FRUSTRATED.
I GOT CALLS FROM JIM BIDEN WHO
WAS READY TO CALL THE CHINESE
DIRECTLY AND SAY THE BIDEN
FAMILY IS PULLING OUT OF THE
DEAL.
ALL WELL DOCUMENTED IN TEXT
MESSAGES, WHAT'S APP AND
E-MAILS.
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS AT THE TIME
BUT APPARENTLY AROUND THAT SAME
TIME HUNTER BIDEN AND HIS
LAWYERS BASICALLY REMOVED ONEIDA
, PUT A WASKO HIS LAW FIRM
IN THERE, AND REPLACE THAT IN
THAT DOCUMENT GETTING PREPARED
TO BASICALLY DIVERT THAT MONEY
INTO THE YZ HOLDINGS.
>> SO THEY WERE SHAFTING YOU
WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE, IT
SOUNDS LIKE?
>> IT IS CALLED FRAUD.
>> I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
EXPLANATION FOR THIS, DO YOU?
>> I AM SURE YOU CAN REACH OUT
TO THE BIDEN FAMILY AND GET
COMMENTS FROM THEM.
>> THIS IS JUST THIS ALONE OF
SEEMS TO ME ENOUGH TO SPUR A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION BY THE
FBI INTO WHAT APPARENTLY IS
FRAUD?
THE FBI HAD THE CONTENTS OF THE
LAPTOP.
THEY HAD IT FOR FOR YEARS NOW.
HAS THERE BEEN AN FBI
INVESTIGATION AND WHAT'S THE
OUTCOME?
>> I AM NOT AWARE OF THEM
FOCUSING ON THOSE SPECIFIC
FACTS.
EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE BEEN
PRIVY OR BRIEFED ON IS THEY ARE
FOCUSING ON MORE LEGACY TAX
STUFF.
THEY SHOULD BE LOOKING INTO
THAT.
>> BUT HUNTER BIDEN HAS NOT BEEN
INDICTED FOR THIS?
>> I AM NOT AWARE OF THAT.
IF YOU ACTUALLY WANT TO GET INTO
MORE DETAIL, THEY ULTIMATELY
EVOLVED FROM USING BE YZ
HOLDINGS TO THEN JUST GOING
DIRECTLY INTO AN ENTITY CALLED
HUDSON WEST THREE AND THAT IS
WHERE HE RECEIVED I THINK OVER
$5 MILLION ACROSS 2017 AND 2018,
OF WHICH HE TOOK A PORTION AND
PAID ON A MONTHLY BASIS TO HIS
UNCLE JIM BIDEN.
I THINK JIM'S WIFE SARAH WAS
INVOLVED.
>> HOW MUCH DID HUNTER EXPECT TO
MAKE FROM HIS BUSINESS DEALINGS
WITH THE CHINESE?
>> NOT ONLY HUNTER, I WASN'T
INTERESTED.
THEY HAD TO WORK ON ME FOR YEARS
TO COME OFF THE BENCH AND GET
INVOLVED.
IN THE SPRING OF 2017 I EXPECTED
CFC WAS GOING TO DEPLOY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THROUGH SINOHAWK AND
I WAS FOCUSED ON TAKING THOSE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND MAKING A
RETURN ON IT.
I EXPECTED TO MAKE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I THINK THE BIDENS THOUGHT THEY
WOULD MAKE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK HUNTER
IN THE END GOT FROM DIVERTING
THIS MONEY?
DO YOU THINK HE RECEIVED THE
MONEY?
>> HE DEFINITELY RECEIVED THE
MONEY.
THE BANK STATEMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE PUBLIC.
HE RECEIVED OVER $5 MILLION.
I THINK IN INCREMENTAL
$1 MILLION IN A LEGAL CONSULTING
FEE TO REPRESENT PATRICK CHO
WHICH IS